In the summer of 2018, the RAND Corporation
issued a massive study of the Gates Foundation's
ambitious, half-billion-dollar effective teacher initiative.
The findings? Mostly negative. RAND
concluded that the initiative failed to make a
dent in student achievement or to
improve teacher quality.
The evaluation teaches some useful lessons.
One: the systems were too time-consuming
and the paperwork too burdensome.
Reforms tend to fail when they redirect
time from students and learning.
Two: even with the new systems in
place, principals continue to inflate
teachers' scores, because it minimized their hassles
and the reforms did nothing to change that.
Three: school systems were reluctant to meaningfully
rethink teacher pay. Now, this doesn't
mean we should give up on teacher
evaluation, but it does mean that
reforming it is much more difficult than
many once anticipated. The challenge
turns out to be less a willingness
to do it than the ability to do it well. And
that's the lesson worth learning.
How do you think we should evaluate teachers?
Let us know in your comments.
Also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.